>>> NOW TO A CNN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH OUR VERY OWN
CHLOE MELAS JEFF BEZOS IS
OPENING UP ABOUT POLITICS,
PHILANTHROPY, THEY'RE WRITING A
CHECK TO DOLLY PARTON TO HELP
HER ADVANCE HER OWN CHARITY
WORK.
WATCH.
>> TALK TO ME ABOUT CHOOSING
DOLLY PARTON.
>> LOOK AT WHAT SHE'S DONE AND
HOW SHE'S LED HER LIFE AND THE
WAY SHE'S DONE IT, BOLD THINGS
ALL WITH CIVILITY AND KINDNESS.
YOU HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
WE HAVE TOO MANY EXAMPLES IN THE
WORLD OF CONFLICT AND PEOPLE
USING ATTACKS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND SO ON AND SO SO.
YOU WON'T FIND DOLLY PARTON
DOING THAT.
>> WHEN YOU THINK OF DOLLY,
EVERYONE SMILES.
SHE JUST WANTS TO BRING LIGHT
INTO OTHER PEOPLE'S WORLD,
THAT'S ALL.
WE COULDN'T HAVE THOUGHT OF
SOMEONE BETTER THAN TO GIVE THIS
AWARD TO DOLLY.
>> THE WORLD IS DIVIDED ON MANY
ISSUES.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE AMERICAN
DREAM IS SOMETHING THAT IS
REALLY STILL ATTAINABLE RIGHT
NOW?
>> I'M AN OPTIMIST.
I THINK THE AMERICAN DREAM IS
AND WILL BE EVEN MORE ATTAINABLE
IN THE FUTURE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I DON'T
LIKE ABOUT THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT IS I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF DIVISION.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE USE CONFLICT
AS A TOOL TO ACHIEVE THEIR OWN
ENDS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A GOOD TOOL.
WE SEE IN YOUR POLITICAL SPHERE
POLITICIANS CRITICIZING OTHER
POLITICIANS, THEIR MOTIVES,
CHARACTERS, CALL THEM NAMES.
ONCE YOU DO THAT IT'S HARD TO
WORK WITH SOMEBODY.
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED THE
CIVILITY AWARD.
>> WE WANT TO AMPLIFY THEIR
VOICES.
THE VOICES THAT ARE NEGATIVE
SEEM TO GET THE AIR IN THIS
WORLD.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOUR NET
WORTH, DO YOU PLAN TO GIVE AWAY
THE MAJORITY OF YOUR WEALTH IN
YOUR LIFETIME?
>> I DO.
THE HARD PART IS FIGURING OUT
HOW TO DO IT IN A LEVERED WAY.
IT'S NOT EASY.
BUILDING AMAZON WAS NOT EASY.
IT TOOK A LOT OF HARD WORK, A
BUNCH OF VERY SMART TEAMMATES.
AND I'M FINDING AND LAUREN IS
FINDING THE SAME THING,
PHILANTHROPY IS VERY SIMILAR.
IT'S NOT EASY, IT'S HARD.
AND THERE'S A BUNCH OF WAYS YOU
CAN DO INEFFECTIVE THINGS TO.
WE'RE BUILDING THE CAPACITY TO
GIVE AWAY THE MONEY.
>> HOW DO YOU DECIDE WHERE TO
PUT YOUR EFFORTS?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY PLACES
WHERE, YOU KNOW, PHILANTHROPISTS
AND ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO DONATE
TO CHARITY CAN PUT THEIR MONEY
TO WORK.
I FEEL YOU HAVE TO DO THINGS AT
TWO TIME SKILLS, YOU HAVE TO
WORK ON THE URGENT, HERE AND
NOW, THE IMMEDIATE.
AND THE LONG TERM.
SO THE BEZOS EARTH FUND IS A
TEN-YEAR COMMITMENT TO WORK ON
THESE REALLY BIG PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE ON SUSTAINABILITY,
CONSERVATION, AND RESTORATION,
THE DAY ONE FUND WHERE WE WORK
ON THE HERE AND NOW, THE URGENT
FOOD SECURITY, HOMELESSNESS,
TRANSIENT HOMELESSNESS.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF IMPORTANT
PROBLEMS IN THAT ARENA TOO.
>> TALK TO ME ABOUT THIS TEAM
THAT YOU TWO HAVE BUILT
TOGETHER.
>> THAT'S A GOOD WORD.
WE'RE REALLY GREAT TEAMMATES.
WE ALSO HAVE A LOT OF FUN
TOGETHER.
AND WE LOVE EACH OTHER.
>> IT'S TRUE.
>> I LOVE HOW WE WORK TOGETHER.
WE LOOK AT EACH OTHER, WE'RE THE
TEAM.
>> IT'S EASY.
WE BRING EACH OTHER ENERGY.
WE RESPECT EACH OTHER.
SO IT'S FUN TO WORK TOGETHER.
>> LET'S BRING IN CHLOE WHO SAT
DOWN WITH THE TWO OF THEM.
IT'S JUST -- IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING IT IS SO HARD TO GET TIME
WITH THEM.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU'RE THE ONE
THEY CHOSE TO SIT DOWN WITH SAYS
A LOT.
>> IT'S THE FIRST TIME WE HEARD
FROM THEM TOGETHER IN FOUR
YEARS.
THE FIRST TIME EVER SINCE THEY
FIRST CAME OUT AS A COUPLE IN
2019.
AND YOU KNOW, HE DOESN'T REALLY
GIVE SITDOWN INTERVIEWS.
IT WAS PEGGED TO GIVING DOLLY
PARTON THIS $100 MILLION GRANT
FRIDAY NIGHT AT A PRIVATE EVENT
AT HIS HOME.
HE GAVE ONE TO VAN JONES FROM
CNN.
BUT WE DID TALK ABOUT
POTENTIALLY BUYING THE
COMMANDERS, AND LAUREN WANTING
TO GO TO SPACE WITH AN ALL
FEMALE CREW.
THIS WAS A WIDE RANGING
INTERVIEW AT THEIR HOME IN D.C.
THAT LASTED OVER 20 MINUTES.
>> ONE OF THE WEALTHIEST MEN,
MOST POWERFUL MEN IN THE WORLD
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE BUILT WITH
AMAZON AND OTHER ENTITIES.
HE HAS BEEN FRETTING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
HE'S SPOKEN OUT AND CLASHED WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE ON WHAT HE
BELIEVES ARE THE REAL ISSUES.
>> HE RESCENTLY TWEETED BATON
DOWN THE HATCHES SO I WANTED TO
KNOW HIS TAKE ON THE RECESSION,
ARE WE IN ONE?
>> WE ARE IN SOME TOUGH ECONOMIC
TIMES.
SOME PEOPLE SAY PERHAPS WE'RE
ALREADY IN A RECESSION.
DO YOU THINK WE'RE IN ONE AND
WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE'RE
TECHNICALLY IN A RECESSION,
ECONOMISTS ARGUE OVER THAT AND
THEY HAVE DEFINITIONS.
I CAN TELL YOU THE ECONOMY DOES
NOT LOOK GREAT.
THINGS ARE SLOWING DOWN, SEEING
LAYOFFS IN MANY SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMY PEOPLE ARE SLOWING DOWN.
THE PROBABILITIES SAY IF WE'RE
NOT IN A RECESSION RIGHT NOW
WE'RE LIKELY TO BE IN ONE VERY
SOON.
SO MY ADVICE TO PEOPLE, WHETHER
THEY'RE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
OR -- IS TAKE SOME RISK OFF THE
TABLE.
IF YOU WERE GOING TO MAKE A
PURCHASE, MAYBE SLOW DOWN THAT
PURCHASE A LITTLE BIT, KEEP SOME
DRY POWDER ON HAND AND WAIT A
BIT AND SEE HOW -- TRY TO REDUCE
SOME RISK IN YOUR BUSINESS OR
YOUR LIFE.
>> YOU TWEETED BATON DOWN THE
HATCHES.
>> UM-HUM.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
IF YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL AND
THINKING ABOUT BUYING A LARGE
SCREEN TV, MAYBE SLOW THAT DOWN,
KEEP THAT CASH.
SAME WITH A REFRIGERATOR OR NEW
CAR.
TAKE SOME RISK OFF THE TABLE.
A SMALL BUSINESS, DELAY CAPITAL
PURCHASES, DO YOU NEED THE NEW
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT?
HAVE CASH ON HAND.
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF RISK
REDUCTION COULD MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE FOR THAT SMALL
BUSINESS IF WE GET INTO MORE
SERIOUS ECONOMIC PROBLEMS.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY THE
PROBABILITIES A LITTLE BIT.
>> ANY IDEA WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
OR WITH YOUR EXPERTISE HOW LONG
THE RECESSION COULD LAST?
>> I DON'T THINK THE MOST
EXPERIENCED ECONOMISTS IN THE
WORLD CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IT'S A CHALLENGING THING TO TRY
TO ESTIMATE.
YOU HAVE TO TRY AND BE
REASONABLE ABOUT IT, TAKE AS
MUCH RISK OFF THE TABLE AS YOU
CAN FOR YOURSELF.
HOPE FOR THE BEST, BUT PREPARE
FOR THE WORST.
>> YOU HEARD JEFF BEZOS RIGHT
THERE SAY IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO
MAKE SOME BIG PURCHASES TO MAYBE
THINK TWICE ABOUT IT FOR RIGHT
NOW.
TO KEEP SOME POWDER ON HAND HE
WAS SAYING.
AND WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A TECH
RECESSION WITH THE LAYOFFS IN
THE INDUSTRY, AND IT'S A REALLY
UNCERTAIN TIME AND, YOU KNOW, WE
ALSO GOT INTO OTHER THINGS LIKE
I SAID, IN SPACE, WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE ON THEIR SATURDAY NIGHT,
HOW THEY FIGHT OVER WHAT MOVIES
TO WATCH.
LATER IN THE DAY WE'LL SHOW YOU
SOME MORE.
>> IT WAS INTERESTING YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE BUZZ AROUND
HIM.
I SAW HIM AND LAUREN AT THE
GALLERY UNVEILING, YOU HAVE ALL
THESE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM HE'S AT
THE TOP OF THE CELEBRITY CEOs,
HE'S A FOUNDER, WHO WAS IN THE
ROOM, JOSE ANDRE, VENUS
WILLIAMS, SERENA WILLIAMS, DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI, CLIVE DAVIS.
YOU KNOW WHO HAD THE BIGGEST
BUZZ?
>> TELL ME.
>> JEFF BEZOS.
>> HE DID GO TO SPACE.
>> YEAH.
>> ON TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE, I'LL SAY
AGAIN, SHE'S PLANNING TO GO WITH
AN ALL FEMALE CREW IN 2023.
>> NANCY PELOSI TOO.
IT WAS A BIG BUZZ AROUND HER AS
WELL.
>> YOU CAN WATCH THE FULL
INTERVIEW ON CNN.COM.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE
WANTS TO SEE.
IT IS SO RARE HE SITS DOWN TO
SPEAK WITH REPORTERS.
>> GREAT INTERVIEW.
>> THANK YOU.